this is a production of Cornell
University and thank you guys all for
being here I am really excited to share
with you what I've been working on for
the last six years in Polara virus
research oh and I just realized my mic
spot on okay better okay um so my
research focuses on plant pathogenic
viruses in the genus Polara virus and
the family Lou do Verity Polara viruses
have a single-stranded positive sense
RNA genome meaning that the genome
itself is protein coding these viruses
moved in both a Fidesz icosahedral
variants unlike many other plant
pathogenic viruses bleurgh viruses are
transmitted exclusively by aphids in a
circulat of non propagated manner if
it's deposit baryons directly into the
phloem shown here in red while they're
feeding the virus then replicates and
moves systemically but never crosses out
of the flow on this phloem restriction
is believed to be an adaptation to
facilitate acquisition by SAP feeding
aphids the symptoms caused by Polara
virus infection vary by host and species
but often include intervening chlorosis
as you can see in this infected hairy
nightshade plant Polara viruses are an
emerging problem worldwide shown here is
a summary of the geographic distribution
of new and emerging Polara viruses in
2018 alone purple stars with pop-out
boxes represent new color of iris
species the same year Klara virus
species were reported for the first time
on eight new hosts shown by blue stars
and in seven new countries shown by
orange stars like other RNA viruses
Polara viruses mutate and evolve
extremely rapidly therefore even species
that have not been an issue in an area
for many years can experience a
resurgence if new strains emerge
additionally the use of insecticides to
control a third vectors is neither
cost-efficient nor effective by the time
a grower realizes they have a Bolero
virus in their field it's often too late
to contain the outbreak
additionally insecticide resistance is a
growing issue in aphids
fortunately we have several well studied
Claire virus species that we can use as
models potato leaf roll virus or peel RV
effect solanaceous plants and causes a
net necrosis disease of potato that was
once an enormous problem in the United
States
turnip yellows virus or tu ivy is a
pathogen of brassicas and is currently
of economic importance on canola decades
of research have generated an excellent
toolkit for studying these two viruses
including infectious clones which allow
us to inoculate plants by agro bacterium
infiltration theory on purification
protocols a wealth of homemade and
commercially available antibodies which
are useful for Eliza
Western blot and other applications and
protocols for rearing 1/3 vectors
finally I've labeled this box virus
mutant library but the real resource
here is Stewart Grey who is one of the
foremost Polara virus biologists in the
world and we're fortunate to have him
located here at Cornell just across the
street from our lab Stewart has been
incredibly generous with his expertise
his equipment and of course his mutant
library I shouldn't do that and this
project would not have been possible
without him another advantage to working
with polio viruses in general is the
small size of their genome which is
about 5.8 kilobases and encodes only
nine known proteins which I'll walk you
through briefly p0 functions in
suppressing hosts silencing which is the
primary plant defense against viruses p1
and p2 and kotipalli protein and a
fusion protein which are important for
replication p3 a and p4 function and
movement and plants P 3 and P 5 are
structural proteins which form the
capsid I'll talk about these a little
more in the next slide and the functions
of p6 and p7 remain mysterious as
mentioned previously Polara viruses have
icosahedral variants the capsid is made
primarily of coat protein or CP shown in
blue and in courted encoded by or 3
Hager sporadic read-through of an Amber
stop codon causes translation through or
v producing a C
terminal extension called the
read-through domain or RTD shown here in
orange the resulting read-through
protein or RTP is incorporated into the
capsid at a low frequency with the RTD
projecting outward from the capsid
surface the RTD is also found in an
unincorporated form which has been shown
to have its own functions mutational
analyses primarily from Stuart's lab
have pinpointed regions in the CP and
RTD which are important for very on
assembly a fortress mission movement and
plants and restriction to flow um tissue
in spite of the many tools available for
Calero virus research the structural
biology of these viruses remains
difficult to study for starters Polara
viruses are phloem limited which means
that they're located in tissue that's
hard to lyse and hard to separate from
other tissues this also means that the
overall virus titer in the plant is
quite low as most of the plant cells are
actually not infected consequently it's
difficult to obtain a large quantity of
pure baryons
because of these and other challenges
there is no publicly available crystal
structure for any polio virus virion or
structural protein which limits our
ability to infer how mutations impact
structure one technique commonly used
for studying polio virus structural
biology is an RNA z' protection assay in
this assay barians extracted from plants
are subjected to a short treatment with
RNA s-- which digests any RNA that is
not protected by a capsid after rnase
treatment the protected RNA is extracted
and used for cDNA synthesis and the
presence of the viral genome is assessed
by conventional PCR in baryon
preparations that have not been
subjected to RNA Streetman the genome is
intact for both the wild type virus and
this Delta CP mutant which is a mutant
that does not produce Furion's
however the absence of the capsid in the
Delta CP mutant leaves the genome
vulnerable to RNAs resulting in near
total degradation of viral RNA after
RNAi Streetman this assay can be used to
check whether mutations in the CP and
RTP affect virion assembly so this is an
example of one mewn from Stuart's lab
that has been test
in this way this mutant contains two
point mutations resulting in a leucine -
prolene and a histidine - prolene
substitution
although the viral genome is produced we
can see clearly in an rnase protection
assay that variance are unstable or
incomplete indicating that this mutation
disrupts capsid formation or stability
RNA protection and other classical
approaches to studying culero viruses
have connected many mutations in the cpe
and RTD to defects in virion assembly
movement in plants and atha transmission
yet we're still missing something how is
it that these small changes in Co
protein sequence lead to a change in
function and the missing link here is
protein structure these mutations can
result in small or large perturbations
in coat protein structure which in turn
may impact virion assembly or
interactions with plants and atha to
proteins these changes are especially
important for Polara viruses which move
systemically and plants and a Fidesz
Furion's however as I mentioned before
there are no publicly available crystal
structures for any poliovirus virion or
structural protein without knowing what
these proteins look like how can we link
these changes in sequence to disruptions
in the viral life cycle to try to
approach this problem from another angle
we applied protein interaction reporter
or PIR technology PR technology utilizes
a mass spec compatible cross linker
developed by our collaborator Jim Bruce
at the University of Washington in
Seattle this is a schematic of the PIR
cross linker at the bottom are two
reactive groups which react with solvent
exposed lysines on the surface proteins
applying this cross linker to a mixture
of protein complexes allows us to freeze
protein protein interactions after
cross-linking we break the proteins into
smaller pieces by digesting with trypsin
a biotin tag on the cross linker allows
us to enrich for cross-linked peptides
before we run the samples through the
mass spec next a massive coded reporter
at the center of the cross linker allows
us to pinpoint cross-linked peptides in
the mass spec targeting them for further
analysis
finally the mass spec cleavable bonds
connecting the reactive groups to the
rest of the cross linker enable
isolation and fragmentation of the
peptides and each cross-linked pair the
mass spec cleavable bonds are what make
PIR revolutionary as they're what allow
us to easily determine which peptides
are cross linked to one another
application of the PIR cross linker to
protein complexes yields several types
of cross links some like these ones in
pink occur between two interacting
proteins the cross linker can also react
with two nearby reactive sites on the
same protein as shown by the yellow
arrows finally we see some dead end
cross links like these ones in black
between reactive sites and water these
cross links are actually still useful
because they tell us which regions of
the protein are solvent exposed because
PIR technology identifies not only which
proteins interact with one another but
also which residues were cross-linked it
gives us information that we can use for
structural modeling this is great
because computational modeling without
any other information often results in
hundreds or thousands of possible models
as shown by the myriad of ways we can
imagine putting this green protein and
blue protein together however finding a
cross link for example between the red
dots on these proteins tells us that
these red dots have to be near enough
for a cross linker to connect them using
the length of the cross linker arms as a
distance constraint we can instantly
eliminate many of the possible models
this brings me to the research portion
of my talk which I'm going to divide
into two sections based on the type of
cross links that we found in the first
section I'll talk about some work in
structural biology of Polara viruses
using PIR guided modeling in the second
part of the talk I'll detail how we used
PIR to explore host virus interactions I
also want to remind you that my
experiments are going to alternate
between the use of our to model polio
viruses potato leaf roll virus and
turnip yellows virus okay so let's talk
about structural biology in the absence
of a crystal structure we can use PIR to
make guided predictions using
computational models
in fact michelle heck juan chavez and
stacy de blasio have already used PIR
cross-linking data to generate
computational models of the PLR Vico
protein trimer and my goal in this first
section of my talk is to extend these
techniques to TU IV even though the co
protein sequence is remarkably well
conserved across bolero viruses these
fires pilar b and tu IV have different
hosts and can cause them to different
symptoms so we didn't know whether the
interaction topologies would be
conserved to apply PIR to study Polara
viruses we first do a protein extraction
from infected tissue then we do a crude
theory on purification which enriches
for very ons while retaining some host
virus interactions applying the PIR
cross linker to this sample
lens data about interactions between
viral proteins as well as interactions
between viral and host proteins
importantly the atha transmissibility of
every crude virion purification is
tested prior to cross-linking to ensure
that the samples contain intact
biologically active variants so here's
what we found when we applied this
workflow to tu ib this is a schematic of
the TU IV co protein sequence shown in
blue with the optional read-through
domain shown as an orange dotted arrow a
lysine at position 150 in the Koch
protein was found cross linked to
another lysine at position 179 an
important limitation of PIR is that we
can't tell whether these cross-linked
lysines were on the same coat protein
monomer or on adjacent monomers which
limits our ability to use cross links
like this one for modeling although
they're still useful remarkably this
exact cross link was also found in pilar
v we can be certain that these cross
links are truly homologous to one
another because not only are the amino
acid positions similar but also the
peptides found cross-linked were nearly
identical differing by only a few amino
acids we also found a cross link between
two identical lysines found at position
179 in this case we know that this cross
link had to occur between two adjacent
CP monomers because this peptide only
occurs once in each molecule
we call this kind of cross-linked an
unambiguous homodimer
and this is the most useful kind of
cross-linked for modeling this
cross-linked was also perfectly
conserved in Pilar B so now that we have
some cross-linking data how do we use it
for modeling first I used a tool called
ight assert to predict the structure of
a single coat protein monomer by
homology modeling you can see the
structure here it consists of an S or
shell domain which forms the surface of
the capsid and in our domain which
interacts with RNA inside the capsid
next I model the multum or it's not
computationally feasible to model the
entire virion so instead we choose a
subset in this case the Koch protein
trimer which is the basic unit of the
capsid the classical trimer makes up one
face of the virion
I use sim duck to assemble the monomer
into plausible trimers in as many
different ways as it can while keeping
my cross-linked residues within a
certain linear distance of each other
based on the length of the PIR
cross-linking arm without the distance
constraints this analysis produces
hundreds of models but our cross-linking
data and narrows it down to only 77
finally I fed these 77 models into a
script which calculates the shortest
solvent accessible distance between the
cross-linked residues this is important
because linear distances often pass
through other parts of the protein which
our cross linker can't do you can think
of this as the difference between going
from here to Australia by tunneling
through the planet versus taking an
airplane over the planet's surface after
all of these calculations I ended up
with two trimer models that fit our
distance constraints so those two models
are shown here with the cross-linking
sites used for distance constraints
shown space filled in different colors
when we compare these to the most recent
peel RV trimer model from Stacy de
Blasio's paper we can see that model a
is more similar in shape but still isn't
an exact copy part of the reason we
obtain two rather different models for
the trimer is that there are many
different ways that monomers contact
each other in variants for example these
pink points are a three-fold axis of
symmetry at the centre of the classical
trimer whereas the yellow and green
contacts occur at the vert
it's very on our model changes depending
on where in the larger 3d structure we
think the cross links occurred model a
as well as Stacy's model fit best at the
six fold axis of symmetry as shown here
model B on the other hand places the
cross links at the threefold axis of
symmetry making this a true trimer model
so you might remember earlier I
mentioned this LH mutant from Stewart's
lab this is the one that he tested by
RNA spre tection and found that doesn't
it doesn't make stable variance so if we
highlight these mutated residues on
model a of the TYB tremor we can make
some predictions about why this might be
these two mutated residues are located
near the threefold axis of symmetry in
this model which is likely a really
important area for assembly and
stability of the trimer additionally the
histidine at position 108 has a
positively charged sidechain and is near
a negatively charged aspartate on the
neighboring monomer mutating this row
this histidine to prolene which is
hydrophobic would greatly disrupt the
salt bridge and favorable interaction
this is just one example of how a
structural model can be used to bridge
the gap between sequence and functions
so what's next the high degree of
conservation of structural cross links
between T u IV and PLR V provides
grounds for extension of these data to
other pool arrow viruses this is
important because it allows us to make
structural predictions for Polara virus
species that don't yet have
well-developed tool boxes including
newly emerging species we also of course
would like to be able to confirm our
predictions by solving some structures
and in fact we're doing this in
collaboration with josh Chaffee who's an
expert in x-ray crystallography and cryo
IAM here at Cornell he's in the audience
today and actually I did some early work
trying to solve the structure of the
Pilar V theory on by cryo a.m. but
didn't have time to overcome some of the
technical difficulties we had early on
Josh's lab is also trying to solve the
crystal structure of these structural
proteins Carl Schultz a grad student in
Josh's lab is actually very close to
solving the structure of
ecoute protein and he is also working
with Jenny Wilson who's a grad student
in our lab do you solve the structure of
part of the read-through domain and the
results from this project have been
really really exciting and if you want
to hear more about them I would
encourage you to look out for their
papers or to try to visit one of their
seminars on campus in the meantime these
PIR data are the only measurements we
have of structural proteins for polio
viruses and we expect these data will
continue to be important even as we get
closer to solving the structures this
paper is an example of a structure which
was obtained primarily through cryo a.m.
but utilized cross-linking data to
resolve an area that was otherwise
ambiguous before I move on I want to
mention one more thing although all of
the virus virus interactions I've talked
about so far have been between
structural proteins encoded by Orff's 3
and 5 PIR can also detect interactions
with any other viral proteins that are
present in our crude theory on
purifications and in fact my dataset
included two cross links between the t u
IV coat protein and a lysine located in
the peptidase domain of the viral p1
poly protein this interaction has never
been shown before and is interesting
because of a very old mystery in the
color of iris field this is an image of
a Western blot using an antibody that
recognizes structural proteins the far
left lane contains crude protein
extracted from PLR V infected plants you
can see that there's a clear band
visible for the coat protein at 23 kilo
daltons and for the full-length
read-through protein at about 80 kilo
daltons there's also a faint signal
between 50 and 70 kilo daltons which is
hard to see here however if we take the
same plant tissue and use it for a very
on purification we see a very different
story the co protein band remains as
expected but the full-length
read-through becomes difficult or
impossible to detect meanwhile the faint
bands we saw earlier resolved into a
handful of clear bands between 50 and 70
kilo daltons these bands are believed to
correspond to truncated forms of the
read-through protein for many years
researchers weren't certain whether
these truncations were an artifact of
the purification protocol
or whether they had some biological
function however this paper published in
2014 showed for the first time that the
truncated RTP did have a function
authors found that both the full length
and truncated forms of the RTP were
absolutely required for efficient
systemic movement in plants they
hypothesized that only the truncated RTP
is incorporated into the RIANZ
accounting for its enrichment in
purified preparations but that
unincorporated full-length RTP interacts
with other host proteins to facilitate
movement however the authors were not
able to determine how RTP truncation
occurred my finding of a cross link
between the CP or RTP and a lysine in
the peptidase domain of another viral
protein suggest the Polara biases may
perform this truncation using their own
viral protease this is supported by an
analysis of the locations of the
putative p1 cleavage sites in the RTP of
Calero viruses as well as others in the
family Lydia Verity in the Koch protein
and n-terminal half of the read-through
domain there are very few putative p1
cleavage sites however we see a massive
increase in the frequency of these sites
in the C terminal half of the RTD
cleavage at these sites would result in
truncated RTP s of 50 to 70 kilo daltons
which corresponds exactly with the sizes
that we see on a Western so in this
portion of the talk we found that these
structural cross links are conserved
between Pilar V and T u IV and we found
a cross link between a viral protease
domain and the co protein which led to
us to postulate a possible mechanism for
our TP truncation and we expect these
data to be useful in the future as we
integrate them with crystal structures
next I want to talk a little bit about
host virus interactions as I mentioned
previously PIR can also be used to probe
host virus interactions as these are
preserved during our crude virion
purification so when I first joined the
HEC lab Stacy de Blasio was working on
this project
she found interactions between pilar v
co protein or read-through protein and
32 different plant proteins this one is
my personal favorite it's a protein
bip which is a heat shock protein and
when Stacy modeled the interaction
between bip which is shown in blue and
the PLR Vico protein shown in green she
found that the Koch protein actually
fits perfectly into bits substrate
binding pocket here you can see a web
logo analyzing the conservation of the
bit binding site among the coat proteins
of other viruses in this family the size
of the letter corresponds to the degree
of conservation not only are the amino
acids that are directly involved in
binding highly conserved they're also
exactly the same motif that VIP is known
to bind to in host proteins indicating
that this motif has evolved in viruses
to mimic the host substrates tip this is
especially interesting because these
residues are a short but highly
conserved stretch of hydrophobic amino
acids in what is otherwise a highly
charged region of the co protein seeing
this we wanted to explore this protein
further and one of my first projects
here was to take this protein and a
selection of others found interacting
with PRB and to try to determine what
the purpose of this interaction was
fortunately there's already a very
well-established system in place for
gene silencing in mikoshi Anna Bentham
Jana our plant of choice this system
uses another virus tobacco R a virus or
T RV to silence genes by virus induced
gene silencing after inserting a
fragment of a plant gene black dip into
one of the halves of the trv genome
young plants are inoculated by agro
infiltration as the virus replicates and
move systemically homologous transcripts
are silenced in new tissue since we
never tried the system before we chose a
relatively simple approach to start I
inoculated plants with TRB containing a
silencing construct and allowed them to
grow for several weeks as shown on the
previous slide
I then inoculated several young leaves
with PL RB by agro infiltration waited a
few days and sampled the infiltrated
area by taking leaf bunches to check
titer by Eliza
because this assay samples locally
infected tissue we expect to be able to
assess changes in virion assembly virus
replication and host defense so here's
what we found when we
used figs to knock down BIP this is a
graph of Pilar VIII tighter in the
control plants which are infected with a
version of trv that shouldn't be
silencing anything and the plants where
BIP expression has been knocked down you
can see that there isn't much of an
effect at three days post infiltration
or dpi
however just two days later a Pilar be
tighter has fallen in the control plants
but risen in the BIP silenced plants
I tested eleven different hosts
interactors in this way and found that
knocking down eight of them affected
tighter during early or late stages of
local infection in later PIR experiments
I also found two cross links that we had
not seen before
between Pilar Vico protein or
read-through protein and a plant
Argonaut one or a go one protein
although stacy had previous evidence
that a go one Co immunoprecipitate swith
prv this was the first evidence we had
of a direct interaction before I go into
the follow-up experiments I want to take
a minute to talk about the role of ego
one and antiviral defense plants primary
defense against viruses is RNA silencing
during replication of Polara viruses and
most other plant viruses a
double-stranded RNA version of the viral
genome is temporarily produced this D s
RNA can be recognized by plant Dicer
proteins which chop it into pieces
the resulting fragments can be small
primary interfering RNAs or si RNAs 22
to 24 nucleotides long
these si RNAs are look loaded into
organic proteins including a go one
forming the RNA induced silencing
complex or risk this complex targets
homologous transcripts for silencing by
a cleavage or translational inhibition
to combat this defense most plant
viruses encode a silencing suppressor if
you remember from the very beginning of
my talk the silencing suppressor protein
for Polara viruses is called p 0 p 0 is
actually believed to function by
preventing assembly of the risk and
promoting degradation of a go one
protein this does not prevent generation
of primary si RNAs by Dicer but it does
keep a go one from using these si RNAs
to target other
transcripts based on this information we
can hypothesize that knocking down a
goal 1 will increase Pilar be tighter to
test this I came back to my Biggs
approach however this time I inoculated
young plants with TRB and Pilar be at
the same time after 2 to 3 weeks when
both viruses had moved systemically I
took leaf punches from young leaves and
assessed titer again by Eliza because
this approach assays systemically
infected tissue it surveys a larger
portion of the virus life cycle here I'm
showing the effect of silencing a go one
on Pilar be tighter at two different
time points each dot represents one leaf
punch pink dots are from the control
plants infected with trv that shouldn't
be silencing anything whereas blue dots
are from plants infected with trv
targeting a go one while silencing a go
one did greatly increase Pilar V titer
in some samples you can see that there
was a huge amount of variation even
between samples taken from the same leaf
because of the enormous variability
between samples there was not a
statistically significant difference
between the treatments so after seeing
these data I wanted to see if I could
alter my samplings method to reduce
variability so reran the previous
experiment but this time I took three
punches from the left half of the leaf
which I've labeled as one two and three
this is a box-and-whisker plot show
variability and here the control plants
are in blue and the eggo one silenced
plants are in pink you can see the
variability is lower in some areas of
the leaf than others next i excised the
midrib of the same leaf as one sample
and took the entire remaining right half
of the leaf as another you can see that
the tighter and both of these samples
was pretty variable finally I took the
PD all of the leaf Peola be tighter was
by far at least variable in these
samples and a clear difference could be
seen between the treatments even though
I've sampled approximately the same
number of plants as before so with this
in mind I set out to do this experiment
one more time this time I took PDL
simples and I also tripled the number of
plants in each treatment because I
really was tired of doing this
experiment
so here you can see that silencing a go
one significantly increased feeler be
tighter relative to the control plants
you can also see that PRD tighter was
significantly more variable in the a go
one silenced plants than in the controls
you might remember that we saw this in
the very first set of experiments I did
too I also checked trv tighter you can
see that silencing a go one also clearly
increased steel RV RV tighter which
makes sense given that a go one has role
in general antiviral defense however
unlike PLR be trv tighter was similarly
variable in the control and a go one
silenced plants this suggests to me that
there's something unique about the
relationship between pol RV and a go one
beyond a go one's role in broad-spectrum
virus defense although I was incredibly
happy to see some low key values after
all of that optimization I've actually
saved what I think is the most
interesting result for last it's a
little bit hard to see in this photo but
infection with trv a go one alone that
is without pilar be present causes some
stunting and morphological defects this
isn't really surprising because a go one
is known to have a role in
transcriptional regulation during
development that said these plants are
still very much alive and will even
eventually flower pilar the infection on
the other hand causes very mild symptoms
even when our control version of trv is
present however if you combine TR v a go
one and Pilar V infection the plant
withers away and eventually dies to
understand why this might occur we need
to think about all the factors
influencing ao1 levels in these plants a
gawad protein is made by translation of
a go one mRNA when Pilar B is present it
produces p0 which promotes degradation
of a go one protein to facilitate virus
replication TR v a go one also works to
knock down a go one but it does so at
the transcript level from this
information we can hypothesize that TR v
a go one and Pilar be individually not a
go one down but not out however when
both are combined a go one drops to
leave
full levels this is supported by work
from other labs showing that a go one no
mutants in a rabid ops Asst are lethal
all of this suggests that puke glare
viruses must highly control P zero
activity knocking down a go one
increases virus tighter but if you knock
down too much the host dies this brings
me back around to the cross link between
PRV coat protein and a go one what if
the purpose of this interaction is to
protect a go one from p0 this would be
an elegant way to maintain a go one
homeostasis as far as tighter and likely
direction of p0 increase more CP is also
produced to counteract P zeros effect
this hypothesis has mixed support from
qPCR data the expression of a go one is
almost identical in control plants
regardless of whether or not the plants
are co-infected with P LRV meaning that
PL are the infection alone doesn't
significantly disrupt ego 1 homeostasis
however PL r B infection has a
noticeable effect in plants infected
with TR v targeting a go one in fact pRb
infection in these plants increases a go
one expression likely in an effort by
the plant to compensate for p0 z' effect
at the protein level although it's
important to note that this increased
expression may not result in increased
levels of a go one protein so this seems
to contradict our hypothesis the
presence of the co protein should shield
a go one from p0 especially because we
know from the previous data that the
titer is very high in these plants but
we already know that the coat protein
can't be 100% effective at preventing a
go one degradation or there would be no
point having p0 at all so maybe the
plants are more sensitive to even the
reduced action of p0 when I go one is
already knocked down at the transcript
level I'm still working on testing this
hypothesis but I think there are
interesting implications for the data I
already have regardless of how the next
experiments turn out knocking down a go
one effects Pilar V tighter in a much
more complex way than tiara be tighter
suggesting that there's something unique
about the a go one Polara virus
relationship this is also supported by
the cross link we found
between coke protein and egg o1 we
definitely have evidence that the
strength of p0 is a balancing act
between suppressing host defense and
killing the host and a1 homeostasis is
not affected by p lr v infection alone
this led us to develop a hypothesis
about the function of the CPO 1
interaction so in this second half is
the talk we've assessed the effect of
knocking down some post interactors
during Pilar B infection and developed a
method to test these interactions using
virus induced gene silencing we also
found a direct interaction between a go
one and Keillor Beco protein or
read-through protein and we've seen
evidence that Polara viruses must
modulate p0 activity to prevent host
death okay so I know I just gave you 6
years worth of data in 30 minutes so I
want to wrap things up by reiterating
what I think are the main point findings
of this research in the first part of
the talk we found that the interaction
topologies of poliovirus coat proteins
are conserved which sounds relatively
trivial but is actually really important
because if the co protein interactions
don't change between Polara virus
species with different hosts this means
that these species specific differences
are not encoded in the co protein
topologies since Polara virus has moved
as virions and plants we can hypothesize
that host specificity must then be
encoded in the read-through domain by
the process of elimination we've also
demonstrated for the first time that PIR
successfully identifies direct
functionally relevant interactions
between Polara viruses and their hosts
this is also not trivial we knew a very
few direct host virus interactions
previously and finding these
interactions was a matter of luck or
screening using yeast two-hybrid or
other high-throughput approaches which
are very time and resource intensive and
don't always identify interactions that
are functionally relevant not only have
we found many new host interactions to
explore but we've also made a huge
technological leap forward in the field
finally i didn't show all of the data
for this but in my biggs experiments I
found that knocking out most of the host
proteins that we identified as
interacting with Galera viruses by PIR
actually increased valera virus titer
this was a really surprising results
because we were expecting to find at
least an equal number of interactions
that are important for virus replication
or movement as for defense there are a
couple of ways that we can explain this
it's possible that plants really just
throw everything that they have at
viruses to try to prevent replication
and so most host virus interactions
actually represent the plant's attempts
to defend itself alternatively we know
that circuitous is that the circulat of
transmission the mode of Calero viruses
requires prolonged a third feeding for
acquisition and transmission while it's
beneficial for viruses with other
transmission modes to sacrifice their
hosts in an effort to produce as many
baryons as possible Polara viruses must
keep their hosts alive and attractive to
affix maybe the reason we see an
increase in tighter when we knock out
most in our host interaction partners is
because the function of these
interactions is actually to limit virus
replication to wrap things up real quick
I want to talk briefly about some
potential future applications and
impacts for this research I'm really
interested to see how these data could
be applied to other non model Polara
virus species including some of the
newer emerging viruses these types of
data could also be useful for the
development of interdiction molecules
which are molecules specifically
designed to interfere with biological
process Angela Cruz a grad student in
our lab is actually working on the
development of interdiction molecules to
prevent transmission of the bacteria
that causes citrus greening disease so
if you'd like to learn more about that
then you can look for her papers and
seminars I also think that this
technology has some potentially
interesting applications for gene
editing and particularly in the
development of resistant cultivars so
this is a paper from 2011 detailing the
development of potato cultivars
resistant to three strains of potato
virus y which is a podium is thats one
of the most important potato pathogens
today like polio viruses PBY has a
single-stranded RNA genome and encodes a
viral genome leaked protein or vpg which
binds to the five prime end of the viral
genome DPG then binds to a host
elongation factor in this case
for ii to recruit a host ribosomal
complex to initiate production of viral
proteins previous screens had identified
AI f-4e alleles and other plant species
which were fully functional but to
contain small polymorphisms that
prevented binding to vpg conferring
resistance to po d viruses in the study
the authors use targeted mutagenesis to
transfer those polymorphisms in the
potato the resulting transgenic lines
are numbered here on this graph with the
wild-type and other control lines on the
far right you can see that all of the
transgenic lines were almost completely
resistant to all three tested strains of
PBY whereas the controls were highly
susceptible
I believe that PIR guided modeling has
the potential to achieve the same end
result for polio viruses but in a much
shorter time frame we have already
established that PIR successfully
identifies functionally relevant host
virus interactions which is the first
step in developing a resistance strategy
like this we can also use PIR data to
model the interaction between the host
and viral proteins predicting where the
viral protein binds if this binding site
is located in an area that can be
mutated without affecting the host
proteins native function we can perform
gene editing to knock out the
interaction without affecting the
proteins native function this is
especially important because many of the
host proteins we found interacting with
kill our V and T u IV have important
roles in metabolism and development and
can't be knocked down or out without
causing significant and sometimes lethal
effects and this is only the beginning
now that we finally have the ability to
more directly explore structural biology
and protein protein interactions we can
try to tackle some of the oldest and
most important questions in Lutie
ovarian biology how do colera viruses
interact with their hosts can we
interrupt virus replication or movement
what's the structure of the polio virus
very on and what governs its assembly
can we design molecules to prevent
assembly or disrupt host virus
interactions
how do Polara viruses cause symptoms and
yield losses in host plants can we use
this information to reduce the impact of
these viruses and finally atha
transmission is largely a black box
application of PIR to a papyrus
complexes could greatly helped us to
understand circulat of transmission of
these and other viruses so overall I
think these data and this technology are
really exciting and give us the ability
to leap years ahead in our understanding
of klara virus biology and I hope I've
convinced you of that too before I take
questions I'd like to take just like one
minute to to thank a couple of the
people who have made all of this
possible so I've been fortunate to have
many amazing mentors in my time here my
adviser michelle tech has been a
constant support source of support and
inspiration anyone who has met her knows
that her seemingly endless energy and
capacity to generate new ideas is truly
incredible and from Cold Spring Harbor
to many government shutdowns we've been
through a lot together and I'm so
grateful to have been able to take this
journey with her I also want to thank my
committee all of whom are amazing and
I'm so honored to have been able to have
their feedback also Stacy de Blasio laid
the foundation for so much of this work
and has been an incredible sounding
board friend and teacher and I could not
have done any of this without her and to
my many other mentors who have helped me
to become a better scientist a better
teacher and a better communicator thank
you I know everyone says this but I
truly have the best collaborators in the
world not only Jim Stewart and Josh who
I mentioned previously but also a very
broad and very neat Ziegler graf who
enabled all of the work with tu ivy my
husband Dave has been my rock through
even the hardest days in the lab not
only has he been unwaveringly
supportive and encouraging but he has
personally contributed to this project
through many late nights helping me
inoculate plants I would also not be
here today without my family especially
my sister Midori and my parents pictured
here in their adorable Christmas attire
who have been a constant source of
strength inspiration and love you guys
are the best and I'm so lucky to have
you
finally I'm so grateful to have met so
many brilliant kind and creative people
here and I especially want to thank
Angela Cruz who has had the misfortune
of spending so much time with me that
we've started taking on one another
sander isms she's she's picked me back
up so many times after I fallen and I
truly don't know what I would do without
her so thank you all of you for your
support and for listening today it means
a lot to me and at this point I think we
have time for a couple of questions so
I'll start by taking a question from
Ithaca Andie protein had a modulating
degradation of a go and you showed in
your model or you show your data that
says if you have a big knockdown plant
that's inoculated with the virus you see
this like dead plant and you're saying
that that could be due to take is going
to lower the threshold for so what do
you think would happen if you
overexpress the protein or
yeah so Annie was talking about this ago
one story and my hypothesis for the co
protein interaction protecting a go one
from p0 and was wondering if maybe if we
express over express the co protein or
did something else to kind of mess with
this system if we could maybe provide
some support for this hypothesis and
that's actually is something that I'm
working on I'm using something called a
silencing suppression assay which I just
barely didn't get done in time for this
talk but basically I'm trying to see if
I can over express the coat protein and
see a difference in how well a go one is
degraded by p0 Josh yes do you know how
that maps to our structural data like
there's a correspond to where we work we
see structurally or you know
does it like to the point where we have
structure I don't remember off the top
of my head I have looked at that and I I
can't remember what the what the results
were but that would be really
interesting to check to see where those
putative cleavage sites are distribution
right it drops off very pretty strongly
at a certain point my question is you
know we have a structure of the internal
part of it so does that map to where
that drops off and what you know what we
need for structure that's all well and
it would I think it would also be
interesting to see whether the putative
cleavage sites that we do see in the NR
TD are maybe protected in the structure
so maybe they could be present but
aren't being recognized by p1 which
could explain why we never see cleavage
there so yeah definitely are there any
questions from Geneva or other remote
audiences yeah I think we're about out
of time but if anyone has any other
questions feel free to come and grab me
afterwards so thank you guys this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu